Queridos amigos, en 1971, el Premio Nobel
de Economía, Simon Kuznets, afirmó que había
cuatro tipos de países de acuerdo a su desempeño
económico:
los países desarrollados, los países subdesarrollados,
la Argentina y Japón.
Amigos, Argentina y Japón son dos países
que se enfrentan hoy a muchos problemas económicos
pero cuya evolución en el tiempo no podría
haber sido más diferente.
Ha sido una trayectoria tan distinta que nos
surgen algunas preguntas:
¿Qué diferentes caminos han seguido la Argentina
y Japón?
¿En qué se han parecido?
¿En qué han sido diferentes?
¿Por qué el país nipón, una isla rocosa
y sin recursos naturales pudo progresar, y
por qué la Argentina con un enorme territorio
y una enorme abundancia de recursos no puede
escapar de su estado de crisis crónica?
En este vídeo te lo contamos.
(CAMINOS OPUESTOS)
¿Hay acaso países “condenados” al éxito
y otros al fracaso?
¿Son los recursos naturales una bendición
o un castigo?
¿Cómo era la economía de Argentina comparada
con la de Japón en la primera mitad del siglo XX?
Amigos, a comienzos del siglo XX las diferencias
entre la Argentina y Japón eran abismales…[Claro
que en sentido inverso a lo que ocurre hoy.]
Argentina era un país mucho más desarrollado,
tenía recursos naturales, una población
bien formada y un comercio abierto al mundo.
Era toda una potencia.
Mientras tanto Japón era un país mucho menos
desarrollado y con instituciones muy tradicionales.
Si nos hubieran pedido un pronóstico en aquel
momento probablemente todos hubiéramos aventurado
que la Argentina continuaría compitiendo
por ser el país más rico del planeta mientras
que en el caso de Japón la lucha sería por
poco más que la subsistencia.
(Tal vez, lo que más diferenciaba a estos
dos países eran los recursos naturales.
Mientras que el territorio argentino es fértil
y está lleno de recursos naturales, la madre
naturaleza nunca fue generosa con los japoneses.
Japón es una pequeña cadena de islas rocosas,
con muy poco territorio habitable, expuesto a todo
tipo de catástrofes naturales y sin prácticamente
recursos naturales.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, en 1945, la segunda
guerra mundial terminó con el lanzamiento
sobre Japón de las dos únicas bombas nucleares
que se han utilizado en una guerra.
En ese momento este país estaba arrasado.
Las ciudades, las infraestructuras y la industria
habían sido en gran medida destruidas, más
de 3 millones de japoneses, especialmente
jóvenes habían perdido su vida y los más
de 10 millones de soldados que retornaban
del frente no tenían trabajo.
En 1945 nadie hubiera apostado por el futuro
de Japón.)
Insisto, lo que si hubiéramos hecho prácticamente
todos hubiera sido, sin duda, apostar por
el futuro de Argentina.
Amigos, a principios del siglo XX, este país
era algo así como el faro de Latinoamérica.
Su economía estaba entre las 10 mayores del
planeta, tenía los niveles de desarrollo
social más altos, su red ferroviaria no paraba
de crecer, el sistema educativo estaba muy
desarrollado y el país tenía una gran participación
en el mercado mundial de capitales.
(Cómo ejemplo, podemos recordar que en aquellos
años, Argentina era uno de los principales
receptores de inversión directa europea,
uno de los mayores exportadores de bienes
primarios del mundo y el segundo destino para
los inmigrantes del viejo continente - sí
por aquella época alemanes, italianos españoles
emigraban en masa a la Argentina.)
[Vamos, que era un país que miraba de tú
a tú a los mismísimos Estados Unidos.]
Esto es lo que explica, cómo en aquellos
años la ciudad de Buenos Aires no tenía
nada que envidiar ni a Londres, ni a Nueva
York ni a ninguna otra ciudad del mundo.
Y encima durante la Segund Guerra Mundial
ni ni siquiera participó en el conflicto.
[De verdad no me digáis que no hubierais
apostado por la Argentina.
Yo hasta el último centavo]
Sin embargo, esperad un momento… porque
las cosas pronto empezaron a cambiar.
Echad un vistazo a este gráfico.
A comienzos del siglo XX, el PIB per cápita
de Argentina era el triple que el de Japón.
La brecha se mantuvo hasta el fin de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial.
Sin embargo, a partir de la década de los
50 ya se empieza a observar un cambio significativo,
de repente Japón empezó a recortar la diferencia
a toda velocidad de tal forma que a finales
de los años 60, el país del sol naciente
ya había superado a la Argentina.
Desde entonces la distancia no ha hecho más
que crecer.
Así que la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es, ¿Qué diantres ocurrió para que esto
ocurriera?
¿Qué hizo Japón que no hizo la Argentina?
Atentos
(JAPÓN VS ARGENTINA)
El territorio de Argentina es 7, siete veces
más grande que el de Japón, mientras que
la población argentina es apenas un tercio
de la población nipona.
Pero, ojo, como ya os hemos dicho la densidad
no es la única diferencia.
Además, el territorio argentino, frente a
lo que ocurre con el japonés es muy fértil
y cuenta con un montón de recursos naturales
de todo tipo.
Petróleo, Gas natural, Oro, Plata, Cobre,
Carbón, Hierro, Litio… Literalmente la
Argentina tiene de todo.
(“La Argentina es el sexto país con mayor
cantidad de recursos mineros en el mundo”.)
[Claro que contar con las condiciones naturales
no implica que producir sea algo sencillo.]
Durante el siglo XIX Argentina - los inversores
argentinos - invirtieron muchísimo dinero
en máquinas e infraestructuras para que el
país se convirtiera en uno de los mayores
productores de alimentos del mundo a principios
del siglo XX.
El aquel momento, el sistema político y las
instituciones argentinas, como el derecho
de propiedad o la libertad de comercio animaban
a los inversores a invertir su dinero en la
Argentina.
Por su parte, durante la segunda mitad del
siglo XIX, Japón realizó cambios en esa
misma dirección.
Os lo hemos contado ya aquí en VisualPolitik
en un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
Fue lo que se conoció como la Restauración
Meiji.
Sin embargo cómo los cambios fueron más
lentos y las condiciones de origen más difíciles…
el resultado a principios del siglo XX era
el que ya hemos visto.
Y luego vino la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
(Fijaos, al terminar este conflicto, mientras
que Japón era un país arruinado, quebrado
y estaba destruido,
La Argentina, que lo había pasado mal durante
la crisis del 29, era un país próspero,
incluso era acreedor de Inglaterra y muchos
otros países participantes en la guerra mundial.
Así que… con una posición financiera sólida,
muchos recursos naturales, una población
bien formada, sin la amenaza de guerras o
conflictos, una clase media en expansión
y una enorme demanda mundial de alimentos,
las perspectivas para el país del tango no
podían ser mejores.)
Pero, amigos, vayamos a la cuestión principal,
¿Dónde comenzaron Argentina y Japón a transitar
por caminos tan diferentes?
Pues veréis, tras la segunda guerra mundial
de una forma y una otra Japón fue, poco a
poco, asimilando y copiando muchas de los
elementos que habían hecho ricos a los Estados Unidos.
(En esto tuvo, precisamente, mucho que ver
la ocupación estadounidense al mando del
General Douglas MacArthur, líder del Comando
Supremo de las Fuerzas Aliadas.
Estas fuerzas de ocupación tenían como objetivo
desmilitarizar y democratizar la sociedad
japonesa.
Para conseguirlo se reescribió la Constitución,
y se copiaron muchas de las instituciones
de los Estados Unidos como por ejemplo, la
limitación del poder y el tamaño del gobierno,
la protección de la propiedad privada o la
libertad de empresa y comercio.
Es decir, Japón se abrió al mundo.)
Mientras tanto, amigos, en la Argentina pasó
todo lo contrario.
En febrero de 1946 asumió la presidencia
del país, Juan Domingo Perón.
Con él llegó el auténtico cambio de modelo
para la Argentina.
De pronto el estado empezó a incrementar
su tamaño y su influencia en la economía
y en la sociedad argentina.
Fijaos, se nacionalizaron un montón de empresas,
especialmente las dedicadas al transporte,
la energía y las comunicaciones; se puso
a la banca bajo el control del gobierno y
se aprobaron un montón de restricciones al
comercio exterior.
[Además de un montón de regulaciones de
todo tipo.]
En la práctica, amigos, Juan Domingo Perón
transformó a la Argentina en una especie
de ejército a las órdenes de un caudillo,
su presidente.
(Para poder llevar a cabo sus planes, la Constitución
liberal de 1853 fue cambiada por otro de corte
peronista en 1949.
Durante los 10 años que duró su gobierno
las distorsiones creadas por el estado sobre
la actividad económica fueron tan grandes,
que los argentinos llegaron a tener que comer
pan negro y racionar su consumo de carne )
[Y no precisamente por ninguna moda vegana
ni nada por el estilo, sino por ES-CA-SEZ.
Los productores argentinos preferían dejar
de producir antes que cumplir con los controles
de precios o tipos de cambio que estableció
el gobierno.]
Y ojo porque la salida del poder de Perón
no supuso ningún cambio relevante.
Sí, se reintrodujeron algunas libertades
económicas y se suprimieron algunos controles,
pero el peso, el tamaño y la intromisión
del estado en la actividad económica no retrocedieron.
El gasto público, los altos impuestos y la
inflación habían llegado para quedarse.
Amigos, El giro de timón de la Argentina
dado por Perón se convirtió algo definitivo.
[Y a ello hay que sumarle la inestabilidad
política causada por los golpes militares.
Un desastre que ha provocado que en Argentina
las crisis se sucedan, una y otra vez, cada
5 o 10 años]
El resultado, como todos sabéis, es que hoy
la Argentina ya no es uno de los 10 países
más ricos del mundo, ni tampoco uno de los
25, ni siquiera uno de los 50.
(Según los datos del FMI, en paridad de poder
adquisitivo, esto es teniendo en cuenta la
diferencia de precios, Argentina ocupa el
puesto 62 de los países con mayor PIB per
cápita.
Es decir, está al mismo nivel que países
como Irán, Bielorrusia o Gabón.)
[Y tras la última crisis es de esperar que
caiga aún más.]
Hoy un 32% de los argentinos, 1 de cada 3,
viven en la pobreza.
Argentina es uno de los pocos países del
mundo donde la pobreza crece en lugar de disminuir.
En fin, amigos, así es como evolucionaron
Japón y Argentina.
En VisualPolitik hemos visto con detalle,
en varios vídeos como Argentina y Japón
se convirtieron en lo que son hoy.
Pero, ahora la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es, ¿Podemos extraer algunas claves de la
comparación de estos dos países?
Pues... creo sí.
Fijaos.
(LAS CLAVES)
Vamos a ver, de la comparación entre Argentina
y Japón podemos extraer tres claves, tres
ideas principales que creo debemos tener siempre
muy pero que muy en cuenta.
La primera - dejémoslo claro de una vez - es
que un país no es rico o pobre por los recursos
naturales o el tamaño que tenga.
De nada sirve tener ingentes recursos si no
se explotan adecuadamente.
En cambio un país, como es el caso de Japón,
puede ser muy rico sin tener recursos naturales
o mucho territorio.
Lo que importa amigos, lo que realmente importa
para generar riqueza es el nivel de capital,
de inversión, y de trabajo que hay en un
país.
La innovación y la productividad son muchísimo
pero que muchísimo más importantes que cualquier
recurso natural.
La segunda idea es que el hecho de que un
país alcance un alto nivel de desarrollo
y prosperidad no significa, en absoluto, que
el mismo se vaya a sostener en el tiempo de
forma indefinida.
(La riqueza no existe per se, hay que crearla
permanentemente y adaptarse a los cambios
que se producen en el mundo.
De lo contrario te puede pasar como en Argentina,
que ha pasado de ser el país más rico de
la tierra a estar en el puesto 62.
Y desde luego eso es malo para todos, especialmente
para la población más desfavorecida.
Castigar a la economía productiva es siempre
una pésima idea.)
La tercera idea es que la riqueza no se logra
haciendo que los gobiernos gasten y gasten
y gasten a lo loco.
El gasto público solo se puede financiar
mediante tres métodos: más impuestos, más
deuda pública o dándole a la máquina de
imprimir billetes - es decir, causando inflación.
Los tres son métodos que no provocan más
que crisis y pobreza.
Hay que ser muy exigentes con dónde va a
parar el gasto público si queremos que nuestros
países sean prósperos.
[Y si no os lo creéis echad un vistazo a
Venezuela además de otro a la Argentina]
En fin, amigos, esta es la comparación de
cómo han evolucionado la Argentina y Japón
y qué podemos aprender de ellos.